[Music]
with new resources
and enhanced responsibilities this new
agency will
guarantee meaningful solidarity to
european governments
the new agency will give practical
support to governments
for more effective assault procedures
including help with the relocation and
transfer
of asylum seekers to different european
countries
liars and officers will be deployed in
all
member states the agency will have
its disposable reservable consisting of
500 experts to be deployed immediately
in member states
in need of support there will be no more
delays
in getting the necessary support to be
sent in the member states
facing pressure for the s d
group it was also essential to
straighten
the protection of fundamental rights for
asylum seekers
that's why we made sure the new agency
will have a fundamental
rights officers to monitor what happened
on the ground
this will guarantee all the rights and
dignity
people deserve in our asylum and
reception system
not only will we have a
real fully fledged assault emergency in
the european union
but we have shown that reform of
common european asylum system is
possible